Hello nice to meet you have you all ever
met have you ever met Anna no it's our
first time hi hello how's it going for
you oh it's so far it's going great
great yeah
um so you and the Ted lasso cast just
went to the White House have you ever
been there before did you like that oh
no no it was it was it was fine it was
cool
I just love this photo that's a boss
photo I don't know man I mean could you
get a tour we did get a tour yeah it's
so funny it's so silly to look at us all
there like what are we doing there silly
I think you look very cool thanks man
yeah no it was um it was it was a total
Riot and also wild because I don't know
you see you see the Oval Office so often
in like TV shows and films you're like
is it real is this real when you're in
there you're like this is the real one
right no I've been in it yeah it's crazy
you feel yeah like your whole thing with
West Wing yeah yeah yeah so in the show
we get um Ted's the biscuits yes and
they very kindly gave us this little box
of biscuits with a president of the
United States Steel oh that's cool
that's cute very cool I was like yeah
can I can I can I have another one for
my dad that's thoughtful yeah I love a
thoughtful gift you grew up in DC right
I did yeah did you go to the White House
I did as a kid because I was a childhood
friend of Amy Carter's in the in the in
the Carter White House
yeah and when you go like the camera I
mean again even then which was the you
know analog 70s uh it you know you would
go like for the weekend
you know and you would come back and
like I have a photograph of Amy and
President Carter and myself tobogganing
and you never saw the photographers
would just like show up at the house
yeah yeah crazy we didn't you didn't get
to talking yeah yeah you did you did I
never got that experience on a it's a
little strange because it was like a
childhood accident do you know I mean we
were we were in a program no that's so
cool though to have that memory yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]